[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down one of the big additions
to the Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
sees us meeting some new characters and
this person even ends up as part of the
team come the post-credits scene if
you're wondering who this new character
is then this is the video for you as
throughout it we're going to be breaking
down who philavel is and what she does
in the comics firstly though I want to
give a big shout out to our sponsors
over at comicbookdirect.com I've got
tons of graphic novels and if you're a
physical collector like I am then you
definitely need to check this place out
as it feels it was built for fans like
us they work with all our major
Publishers like Marvel in DC the best
thing about the site is is that if
you're in the middle of a run you can
subscribe to it to get every issue sent
out directly as they release really cool
site and if you use the link in the
description below you're gonna get 20
off your first order they've also got
manga and figures so if you want to get
those brand new Guardians Funko pops and
definitely head over to the link in the
description without the way though thank
you for clicking the video now now let's
get into file level
okay so Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
shows us a lot of the high
evolutionaries experiments along with
animals we discover that he's been
creating platinum hair children that
possess a lot of different abilities
feel like these might be based off the
midwich Cuckoos due to them all looking
the same with the same wet hair but that
might be a reach now we discover that
one's been running non-stop in a
circular treadmill for two hours without
breaking a sweat and then they're
capable of doing complex calculations
unlike rocket though they're not able to
innovate however that may change as we
get further into things now come the
post-create scene we see that one has
joined the guardian's team and we
discover that this is a character played
by Kaizen bursting our own powers she
has to be pretty important to be brought
into the group like this at such a young
age though we don't get much of a
backstory explained we can look to the
comics to see what she can do and also
talk about where things might be heading
in the future in the comics Viola Bell
is the daughter of Marvel and she's also
the sister of Guinness Val in the comics
both were genetically created using
Marvel's DNA okay and there is the
possibility that the high evolutionary
potentially credited her and her sisters
this way in the MCU we met Marvel during
the first Captain Marvel movie and the
villain could have potentially got a DNA
at some point which he used to create
the rest of the kids the high
evolutionary wanted to create the
perfect specimens and thus he may have
grabbed some Cree DNA in order to put
the group together now I think she's
worth talking about is that the
character connects heavily in with
Captain Marvel and she even took over
the mantle at one point her brother
Guinness actually traveled through time
and altered things which eventually led
to becoming Captain Marvel in another
reality Slots of Tommy why me wibbly
wobbly stuff and with a skipping of a
Guinness you might get a more
straightforward version where she grows
into the role you also know that the
Marvels will be set in space and we
could see the Guardians crossing paths
with them which will introduce all the
characters in the comics she debuted in
2004 as part of Captain Marvel 16 and
she brought with a marvelous speed
strength and also stamina like most
Captain Marvel characters she also has
the ability to tap and their energy and
use it as a weapon we see this being
bust out in the post-create scene with a
purple blast that she produces being
similar to dark energy this is something
that love can tap into as well and it's
possible that the pair will meet at some
pointy to them both being a similar age
and tackling the cosmic side of the
universe now a way I think this would
lead perfectly is through the use of the
Naga bands in the comics phyla took on
the name Quasar and with this came the
quantum bands with Ms Marvel having one
of these and the villain Dog Ben
possessing the other I think it would be
great for her to get these at some point
down the line in the case of his Marvel
I actually think that she's gonna lose
the bands at the end of the movie and
she'll then get her powers through her
mutation her Disney Plus show revealed
at the end that she does have a mutant
Gene within her unless they could make
her keep her skill set but push them
through a genetics after losing out on
the bands philavel could get these
herself and then expand her powers
before becoming Captain Marvel at some
point down the line now the Guardians
Comics also have the character as part
of the roster and she joined the group
in in 2008 now this could also set up
the character moon dragon coming into
the MCU one day as the pair ended up
falling in love in the comics but that's
probably a story for decades down the
line it's also important to bear in mind
that in the comics Moondragon is drax's
daughter so they could be going
somewhere with that and him adopting all
the different children now the MCU does
kind of play fast and leaves with the
source material and it often isn't a
one-for-one adaptation often they take
the rough outline of things but they
change it up completely in order to tell
their own stories Venus will probably be
the case of filer but if you want
another Direction they could go then we
can look at the plot leaks for this
movie originally a list of the group at
the end is being called the annihilators
but I think things might have got Lost
in Translation however filer does time
with the annihilation of N and during
that massive crossover was when the
original Quasar died and she ended up
getting the name I don't know mate but
phyla has also taken up the name Marta
and she clash with Thanos at several
points weirdly a lot of the newly
introduced characters are can connected
to him on some levels which is quite a
strange strategy to take as the guy's
dead twice Adam Warlock was someone who
was one of the people who led the charge
against Thanos during most of the
infinity stone story lines and if you
pick up those old graphic novels then
chances are that the story is gonna
center around him heavily you also have
thanos's brother Eros being introduced
in the eternals along with Adam's
sidekick and Ally pip the troll in the
comics phylabella was killed by Thanos
after he was resurrected and all these
characters coming back could tease at
his return that is a bit of a reach but
it is strange seeing so many
thanos-centric characters now making
their debut in the MCU long after his
death we are dealing with the Multiverse
as well uh we've already seen several
versions of him in the other timelines
the one The Avengers fought at the end
of end game was from an offshoot
timeline and during what if we met one
working alongside to Charlotte so there
is the possibility that he may return at
some point and be a threat that all
these characters have to face off
against now on the other side of this
they could just end up in integrating
her into the Captain Marvel stuff I must
admit I did have to double take when I
heard her name as I wasn't expecting her
to be brought across like this kind of
just popped about an hour and for her to
become a Guardians member this quickly
she must have done something special so
in summary I think they might reveal her
and the rest of the girls come from some
form of Marvel's DNA which is how they
possess enhanced abilities and also the
powers these clearly tap into dark
energy and with her being in the
Guardians already she must be a skilled
Warrior I think that all this stuff
going on in space will end up connecting
at some point and along with the
eternals Thor in love we also have the
Guardians doing jobs out there too I
don't know where the Fantastic Four will
take things but there is the possibility
that it may introduce Galactus or a
cosmic level threat slowly we're getting
these kinds of characters slipping into
the MCU and we had the hordes of
Eternity that had several monuments to
them so yeah I think there might be a
big Cosmic storyline bubbling away in
the background that we aren't even aware
of at this point obviously let me know
your thoughts below though on what you
think is happening do you think the
bands will play into it somehow do you
think philavel will take up the Captain
Marvel mantle and yeah just drop your
general thoughts and your theories below
shouldn't probably through time this
entire video but yeah I hope this helped
you understand who file avel is to just
drop her in like this has to be for a
specific reason but we are going to see
how things play out down the line the
Guardians will likely return as well and
though this is marketed as being their
final chapter it's clear there's still a
lot of gas left in the tank with rocket
as the leader anyway thank you for
sticking through the video and just to
let you know we're running a competition
right now giving away the quantumania
steel Buck to three subscribers on the
15th of May all you have to do to be
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character we pick the comments at random
on the 15 then the wins of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch them make sure you check out our
Brighton of the movie which will be
linked on screen now lots of things to
talk about in it especially that ending
so yeah definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace